I'm here with the executive director of
the st. Louis chess club mr. Toney
reached the boss man Tony
this is the 11th year of the club
existence tell us from your perspective
how did the club evolve you know it's
funny the Chess Club in very beginning
was really just going to be a normal
typical club where members could come in
in play some tournaments or maybe take a
couple of classes and each year we've
added something new our first year we
held the u.s. championship the second
year we added the US Women's in the US
Junior Championship we've added the
Sinquefield Cup and now we've added the
grand chest who are overall so each year
the club grows incrementally and not
just for these major events but also our
scholastic programming you know we teach
chess in about a hundred schools in the
st. Louis area now and I'm very proud of
that and of course the same field cup is
the marquee event of the same loose
chess club of the chess summer tell us a
bit about that why is it the mark even
sure well first of all the Sinquefield
Cup is great you know for chess fans
like myself because I get to see all the
great players that you read about in the
magazines and you see on the websites
competing right here in my own little
chess club that we have here in st.
Louis so the Sinquefield Cup is almost
like all of these great players coming
back home to st. Louis we make every
effort to ensure that they have a great
tournament experience and that all of
their needs are taken care of and I
think that really shows in the quality
of play and in the sportsmanship that
you see we're talking about great
players I'm hearing one great garry
kasparov is coming back here at the same
we stopped in September tell us a bit
about that that's right you know it's
always exciting when Gary plays here in
st. Louis
you know he's played a few matches here
he helped us kick off the first year
that we helped the st. Louis rapid and
blitz by being a wild card in that
tournament as well and so Gary's coming
back for chess960 or Fischer random
chess so for those of you who don't know
about that that's where the back row
pieces are all shuffled and you start
with an original position each time so
Gary will be facing off against Fabiano
car you wanna and we have three other
matches that go along with that the top
four Americans against some of the best
players in the world all fish are random
that sounds like an amazing tournament
but in this one who is your favorite oh
boy it's really hard to say you know
whenever you see all of these great
players in such good form I have to say
in the same field Cup if they're the st.
Louis wrap and blitz was any indicator
ding was really in in great
he lost hardly any games I think de
Lorraine would be the favorite in this
one and my final question will we ever
see a World Championship match held here
at the sandwich desk oh boy I sure hope
so you know my greatest you know my
bucket list of events and I'd like to
see in st. Louis absolutely includes a
World Championship being held here and I
could see no better way to do it than
having an American challenging for the
title again thank you very much well we
can only hope for a world championship
match here in st. Louis back to you guys